ouanna bonjour vous êtes devant le
tribunal londonien de westminster là où
vont se dérouler les audiences qu'est-il
reproché à julian assange et choristes
que rex côte hill et bien je le trouve
actuellement justement devant le
tribunal qui est à proximité de la
prison de belmarsh là où est incarcéré
julian assange est bien les etats-unis
lui reprochent d'avoir révélé des
documents top confidentiel concernant
l'armée américaine en irak qui enlève
ganis temps en tout cas peut le voir
peut-être juste derrière moi de nombreux
soutiens sont venus sur place pour dire
non à l'extradition de julian assange
qui est considéré aujourd'hui comme un
lanceur d'alerté un journaliste qui a
reçu plusieurs prix de journalisme vous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi il ya
des gens qui scandent fruits fruits
assange
libérez assange en a pu voir le père
également de julian assange qui est
passée juste il y à un peu plus d'une
heure et qui était très surpris et très
ému de voir autant de monde et et voir
autant de couvertures médiatiques
puisqu'il ya beaucoup de journalistes
présents je vous propose d'ailleurs de
l'écouté l'oppression envers le
journalisme la malveillance constante
des autorités à l'encontre de julian les
dix ans de détention arbitraire sous le
nez des nations unies la torture
infligée à julian sous les yeux de nils
melzer le rapporteur de l'onu sur la
torture
tous ces documents sont disponibles
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'il arrivera aux journalistes
aux éditeurs et à tous les contenus si
cette extradition
cette extradition politique de julian
assange se concrétise
ce sera donc à la justice britannique de
trancher oui ou non de savoir si julian
assange sera extradé vers les états unis
il fait face à 18 chefs d'accusation aux
états unis et il encourt près de 175 en
2 prison aux états unis
merci beaucoup mon amour de l'art en
direct de londres on vous retrouvera
évidemment là tout au long serge de
cette journée poursuivre avec vous cette
audience